[Music]
you literally could have taken any kid
off the corner but you chose me why
these fools of the streets acting like
they got something to prove the only one
a hustle for the money in the flash but
not you you're special
welcome to Atlanta you've got everything
you could have on the culture style and
of course music if you look deeper
there's a whole other side you've never
seen before
welcome to my world I've been working
the street since I was 11 gave people
jobs on the world on jobs I swapped cash
for crypto and redefined the hustle I
choose my crew wisely
scatter that's my mentor another you
miss your favorite student missed
kicking your ass
she's my inspiration you can be whatever
you want to be Neddy
that's my soul everything is moving
smooth like butter preschool changes
you've been operating under the radar
all that's about to change
let's take it to the hospital you know
there's a difference between it now push
down it's no crew they have cartel
connections and they're coming after
everything we have and everyone we love
what's the play here one last score is
so big that we will never have to look
of our sold again we have to go to the
source if we do this there's no going
back
never was I know who you are priest
abandon our business that's not
acceptable I promise I'm gonna take care
we stick to the plan what play with
black men ain't nowhere safe
[Music]
come on let's take a drive
[Applause]
[Music]
you